بتكتيفي قصف المدن الاوكرانيه بعد اخفاقها
في تحقيق نجاحات على الارض في المقابل
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيروت اصابه شخصين جراء
سقوط سقوط ما يعتقد انها طائره مسيره وسط
مدينه بيلجرود معنى
الانميكوليف مراسله الجزيره تامر الصمادي
لنتابع
روايتين روسيا واوكرانيه نبدا معك تامر
الصمادي فيما يتعلق بالروايه الاوكرانيه
الروايه الاوكرانيه هي هي ذاتها لم تتغير
حتى هذه اللحظه ازدهار فيما يتعلق السلطات
الاوكرانيه تنفي ان يكون لها دور في
العمليات المتواصله هناك اخر تصريح
ظهر خلال الساعات الاخيره هو للمتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه الذي قال بان
العمليات لا تزال مستمره لفيلق المتطوعين
الروس بالاضافه الى فيلق حريه روسيا داخل
الاراضي
الروسيه وقال بان هذه العمليات كل الاطراف
المشتركه فيها هم من الروس المعارضين
لنظام بوتين لنظام الكرملين لكن هذه
التطورات ايضا ترافقت مع صور بثتها العديد
من المواقع الاخباريه الاوكرانيه المقربه
من الجيش الاوكراني التي اشارت الى ما
قالت انه استمرار للعمليات وبان تلك
القوات تواصل ضرب المواقع الخاصه بالقوات
الروسيه هناك
وجاءت هذه ايضا التطورات فقط بعد يوم واحد
من حديث لعدد من المستشارين في الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه الذين قالوا بان الحرب سوف تصل
الى العمق الروسي فعلا داخل موسكو وداخل
ايضا الاراضي الروسيه الواقعه على الحدود
وتحدثت او تحدث هؤلاءك المستشارين عن
التطورات ايضا المتسارعه والمستمره
والمتصاعده منذ ايام في بيلوجرود في
المقابل تحدث حاكم
وهي المدينه الاوكرانيه الواقعه على
الحدود مع بيلا جراد عن تكثيف القوات
الروسيه لضرب المناطق ضرب القرى والبلدات
الواقعه على طول خط التماس بين خاركيف
واكد بان القوات الاوكرانيه هناك تصد
محاولات للتقدم تقدم الروسيه بطبيعه الحال
باتجاه المدينه الواقعه شرق البلاد
المتوفره لديك فيما يتعلق
اشخاصا من المشاه او مجموعتين من المشاه
بالاضافه الى دبابات كانت ترافق هاتين
المجموعتين اذا هذا الامر وهذه التطورات
عند المقاطعه الحدوديه يطرح تحديات اساسيه
في المرحله المقبله فيما تسع روسيا لضم
مزيد من الاراضي والمقاطعات اليها يبرز
تحد في احدى المقاطعات الحدوديه وهذا
التحدي جعل القوات الروسيه تكثف من
هجماتها على مقاطعه
قبل قليل الرئيس الاداره المدنيه
والعسكريه الموالي لروسيا في مقاطعه خالكر
تحدث عن تمدد ومحاوله
لاستكمال سيطره داخل كوبيانسك من قبل
القوات الروسيه هذا يحيلنا ازدهار الى
تصريح كان قد قاله
حاكم مقاطعه بيل غرود فيجيس جلاتكوف الذي
قاله ال لا حل لمساله القصف الذي يستهدف
بيل جريد الا بضمه تلك المقاطعه الى
مقاطعه خارجه الى بالغرد واليوم السؤال
الاساس هل هذه التحركات للقوات الروسيه في
خارطه تاتي في هذا الاطار او انها مجرد
محاوله
لضمان هذه المقاطعه الحدوديه بالتزامن مع
هذه التطورات في بلجر ايضا تطورات على
الجبهات المستعره في دانياسك حيث نتواجد
جبهه افدي افكا استمرار للقتال فيها وقتال
محتدم وفق مقاله وزاره الدفاع ونحن نسمع
حين نقترب من هذه الجبهه كيلومترات ضئيله
نسمع هذا القصف وتكثيف هذا القصف المتبادل
ايضا في جبهه مارينكا حيث تقاتل القوات
الشيشانيه التي دخلت على خط القتال يوم
امس حين اعلن رمضان
انخراط قواته في هذه المعارك ايضا هناك
معارك مستعره بين القوات الروسيه والقوات
الاوكرانيه اليوم الطرفان يحاولان فرض
واقع جديد في هذه المقاطعه مقاطعه دانيت
تحاول القوات الروسيه استكمال سيطرتها
باتجاه الاراضي المتبقيه مع الكره
الاوكرانيه وبدورها القوات الاوكرانيه
تقاتل حتى تحافظ على هذه المواقع شكرا
تامر الصمادي